now tonight more decisive action and
leadership from presidents from as we
begin our monologue we have full
coverage throughout this hour now here's
something that the media will not tell
you here's something Democrats that have
been playing politics will not tell you
and I think we should all listen to the
president this is not about politics is
about our American family there are time
there'll be plenty of time for politics
down the road now from day one this
President took aggressive and even
unprecedented steps to prevent the
spread and mitigate the impact of what
is now a global pandemic
we have pandemics from time to time they
had in 2009 and 10 in the obama-biden
administration we'll give you some of
that information in a minute as always
the president's mission above all else
rightly to protect the lives of the
American people it should not be a
partisan issue this is not a political
talking point the coronavirus does not
discriminate we Republicans and
Democrats conservatives or liberals this
is a moment where we should all work
together a lot of people scared
combat and protect American workers from
this disease and of course those that
are most susceptible and of course then
get back to normal
make no mistakes in serious situations
truth matters facts matter and
unfortunately there's been way too much
politicizing of this too much
well untruths being told and actually
even some actually weaponizing what is a
global pandemic that all needs to stop I
hope it will here's what you need to
know there are now around 120,000
individual cases of corona virus
worldwide including an estimated 81
thousand in China where new cases are
now steadily declining by the way China
did not do the world a favor by not
acting sooner they should have acted
earlier they should have been more
forthright they should have been more
honest they were not and meanwhile there
are around 10,000 cases in Italy 8,000
in Iran
nearly 8,000 in South Korea around 4300
people in the entire world have died
from the disease as we now speak they're
around 1,200 cases inside the United
States including 30 American deaths most
of which were from one nursing home in
the state of Washington the average age
of mortality is 80 according to
officials the death rate estimated at
one
percent now the those most at risk are
people with underlying medical
conditions the elderly those with
compromised immune systems people going
through chemotherapy for example or
immuno diseases of some kind for
perspective so far this season there
have been 34 million cases of the flu
20,000 deaths just in the US alone in
other words there have been 1200 cases
of corona versus 34 million cases of the
flu as a senior director at Johns
Hopkins pointed out this week the flu is
having much more of an impact than
coronavirus that's what the these are
facts for more perspective we go back to
2009 that year more than a thousand
Americans had died in a six-month period
from h1n1 better known as swine flu that
virus and 20,000 Americans had
contracted the pandemic before President
Obama himself declared a national
emergency one of his health officials on
day 11 did in fact say it was an
emergency to release some funding got to
tell the truth on all cases but a
thousand Americans at that point had
died ultimately that disease killed
around
well 12,000 plus Americans in his first
year now perspective aside our current
president Donald Trump well he's not
leading from behind
in fact more facts no president has ever
done more acted more quickly to slow the
spread of a disease now keep in mind the
corona virus wasn't even officially
identified in China until we gave it a
name On January 7th December 30th of
last year is when they first said oh we
see that there is a virus that is
showing symptoms of pneumonia we labeled
it on January 7th On January 31st of
this year three weeks later the Trump
administration declared a public health
emergency
no president ever acted that fast
Americans returning from areas most
impacted they were subject to mandatory
quarantines on military bases by the way
the travel ban went into effect
President ordered that On February the
second for all non US citizens who
recently visited China even though most
officials feared it was too soon for
travel restrictions on the political
side of this Joe Biden suggested that
band was xenophobic see
over there they said we're stigmatizing
people from other countries in the
following days the president formed a
task force filled with top scientific
medical medical professionals were
blessed with the best in the world and
they're led by the Vice President Mike
Pence every day he's been updating the
country on February 29th the State
Department issued new travel
restrictions for Italy South Korea and
Iran at the same time the FDA cut
regulations allowing more rapid testing
capacity for coronavirus on March 2nd
president Trump met with pharmaceutical
executives to discuss treatment and
vaccination plans on March 3rd the
administration ordered the CDC to lift
all restrictions on testing on March the
6th the President signed an eight
billion dollar emergency spending
package into law 8.3 billion to be
specific on March the 10th the president
met with the insurance industry
representatives who agreed to waive
co-pays for every American as it relates
to corona related treatment this
afternoon the president met with banking
executives to discuss plans for Coronas
economic impact and the potential
economic and tax relief for workers of
businesses that are directly impacted by
this virus and just moments ago you just
heard the president announced that a
temporary travel ban will be extended to
the continent of Europe excluding the UK
that means there are now restrictions
travel restrictions on continental
Europe South Korea Iran and China now
will we see new cases of corona in the
United States absolutely do we need to
take it all seriously I've been saying
we have to I've been saying we need to
cure I want to cure cancer one day
it's amazing how great our medical
researchers are the best but let's be
clear this administration their actions
in spite of what many have been saying
they have taken unprecedented steps to
slow the spread of this disease doctor
foul chew on this program last night the
president's quick ban on travel from
China likely saved thousands of lives
that one act in three weeks
unprecedented probably literally save
thousands of Americans from contracting
that disease and probably some the
elderly those with underlying health
issues those with compromised
immune systems from yes facing potential
death China meanwhile they've got to be
held responsible for the spread of this
deadly disease their dishonesty their
government secrecy even outright lies
the Wuhan coronavirus was able to spread
unchecked throughout the world now
thousands are dead markets are down
businesses are suffering in part because
China lied suppressed scientist and
frankly tried to cover up the disease
instead of alerting the international
community which would have been the
wiser thing to do the end of the day
it's another important reminder that
China is ruled by a self-interested
well dictator for life with little
concern clearly for the rest of the
world but fear not back here in the US
we do have the best doctors the best
scientists the best medical researchers
the best technology and we have a
president now that is committed to doing
as he said tonight whatever it will take
to save American lives yeah we're in the
midst of a serious situation people are
nervous people are panicked before long
yes we will be back we'll be stronger
than ever before we have faced pandemics
before and when we have what has
happened we find ways we always do